it was very difficult at the time when
we were growing up um
because it was applied to south africa
any sort of consumption that we had
from tv was not something that we could
identify with no one looked like me
on tv and the world just seemed so far
off and so
i couldn't i couldn't um it did not
resonate with me
and so books really helped me to to
dream to go
into um into worlds
far far far away and and and and even
inspire the career that i have today
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance
opposed hello at stanford leap and
birthright xl
welcome to 20 minute leaders today i'm
honored to be joined by sanwa bismiati
senior manager global policy and
government affairs of global citizen
sun sanwa b started her career in
diplomacy and was posted as a diplomat
for south africa and new delhi india
she left diplomacy to join corporate and
has worked for pr agencies
tech and fintech companies including
tbwa's magna carta
cisco and refinitive a london stock
exchange business
currently she is in the ngo space
working for global advocacy ngo global
citizen
she also serves on several boards and
committees including the sa women and
ict forum
broad-based black economic empowerment
ict sector council
and the cisco charitable foundation
trust and owns
several companies her passion is using
technology to address
social ills sanwa bisa mizinhati welcome
to 20 minute leaders all the way from
south africa how are you
thank you so much for having me michael
i'm very good and how are you today
i'm i'm doing great i have to tell you a
son zombie say i've been looking over
your profile the different things that
you're working on
it's inspiring you know the
organizations you're a part of
the mission that you're driving whether
it's as a senior manager
and global citizen working to end
poverty or women in tech or the 10 other
things that you're doing
it's it's just remarkable and i'm
excited in these next 20 minutes to
understand you better and your life and
your experiences
what you've learned about equality and
inequality
and i'd love to quickly just start with
the situation we're in
right now we almost had to reschedule
this episode
because it is very dark where it's
already nighttime and it's winter
and the electricity is not working right
yeah
yeah so in in south africa we have um
something called
load sharing because um the
government has not been maintaining the
electricity
um stations for a long time and also
this is just under capacity in terms of
how many people it can can accommodate
and how many households
it can accommodate at a time and so it
has to go through a process of load
shedding
which is you know any it has different
stages even it gets announced
that at this time of the day you're
going to be your area is going to be
located for an hour two hours
and we've just had to learn to live with
it and live around it
but what the nice thing is is that um
the president recently announced
an increase in one of our policies that
will allow
citizens to generate their own
electricity
but also for private sector to come in
and start
generating electricity that they can
then sell so if any of your listeners
are interested in electricity and they
would like to come into south africa
please let us come in
and and do us a favor amazing and
so this is speaking also to what what it
sounds like is a common thread
around a lot of the things that you're
working on this question of inequality
uplifting societies and and and bridging
gaps
somehow visa tell me a little bit about
your upbringing and what led you
to be almost you know a fighter for
these
for these ideals right so i
i'm an 80s baby and i grew up
a smack bang in in the middle of
apartheid south africa and um
just witnessing and growing up in that
environment has just led me
towards a career path that is interested
in
development and in bridging inequalities
and most of any role in any
organizations that i've worked
i've worked with have lended themselves
or had
values that were bridging the inequality
gap in some way
some shape or form i'm currently working
for global citizen and
as many of your listeners will know
global citizens seeks to end extreme
poverty by 2030
by getting a really great mix of both
policy and pop
to get citizens firstly to be more
involved in
in policy making and in things that
impact their communities and the world
at large
but also then to get governments to
to bridge policy gaps that aren't
addressing
poverty that aren't addressing um equity
as they should and um lastly also
working towards
you know importantly working towards the
sustainable development goals
and meeting them by by 2030 and then i
also do
um other work um within the technology
space i love technology
and just for me one of my greatest
passions is how technology can bridge
the inequality gap
in real time and i get to do this every
single day which is quite fantastic
so i sit on the board of the sa women in
ict forum
and we really do a lot of work around
bridging the inequality gap one of the
other challenges in south africa for
instance is
gender-based violence and so we built
out a platform
um that an engagement an online
engagement platform that links to
government services
to help uh people who are impacted by
gender-based violence to be able to have
access to those
services and also to be able to reach
the services they get from government so
that government can improve
on those on those services so i'm really
really passionate about about
technology and and how it really drives
solutions and innovations
in real time of course technology's not
the only solution there's a whole
combination of things that need to
happen
but technology definitely um bridges the
connectivity gap
amazing and also we we we generally
forgot that you're a board trustee of
the cisco foundation charitable trust
uh now within global citizen
and before we dive into your position
global citizen and what's happening
there
can you paint me you know a picture of
you know where we are today in terms of
the world so we are in
you know almost july of 2021 what what
is the situation around the world in
terms of extreme poverty
and where is global citizen on its path
right so you know we've all just been
through
epidemic most countries are still
currently going through europe and they
make some have successfully been able to
vaccinate um their theirs their citizens
however you know when we as global
citizen losses are doing research on the
impact of the of the pandemic we found
you know that millions of people are
going to go into extreme poverty as a
result of the pandemic
we found um that the
the education uh is going to
digress and more and more children will
actually um drop out of school because
they can't afford to be
online they don't have access to
computers um
teachers don't know how to teach um
digitally they were never prepared
um for for such an instance and and and
just
access to computers you'll be so
surprised michael how many children
actually
do not have access to the internet and
how many adults
know the internet but actually have
never ever used
the internet in their lifetime in many
many developing countries this is this
is a situation
and also hunger and how many how many
people are going to go hungry because
they've lost their jobs many small
businesses have had to shut down even
large businesses
um have actually um had to go into
bankruptcy because of of covert 19
and so all those elements have driven
asset global citizens to launch
something called the recovery plan for
the world
and we've received so much support from
the usa secretary john k
was part of our launch in february
president ramaphosa
here in south africa um we had
a lot of artists who are also part of
that
of that launch and and supporting us in
many many many countries supporting us
on that recovery plan and we did it in
conjunction with the who
dr tedros's office as well as um
the european union commission and
president uh
president van der layne and so really
really important for
us is to get the world back on a path of
recovery
and um we we've identified five issues
which
will actually get the world back into a
path of recovery
the first being ending the pandemic we
recently did a big global
program called rats live where we raised
about 26 million
doses to go through the covex facility
for low
and low to middle income countries and
302 million dollars
which will go to the at accelerator to
help with medical technologies
tests and treatments for low and low
middle income countries
the second sort of focus is around
hunger
and and stopping hunger the third one is
on education and resuming learning but
also bridging the digital divide in
education right
and then the third the fourth one is uh
protecting the planet
um environment and sustainability is a
very important pillar of ours
and lastly um equity and that's really
around driving
economic justice driving inclusion
and just and just gender empowerment as
well as
uh identification of of of human rights
as a whole wow
a lot a lot to unpack now within your
position
in in global citizen um tell me a little
bit about your
your day-to-day work and so and how does
an organization like global citizen
actually you know think through how do
you go and manage these five
you know verticals that you you just
touched on
yeah we are we are quite a um
a really organized uh machine
that works very very well from a global
perspective but also
knowing how to localize our global
priorities
so for instance while we have these big
global
ambitions we also look at countries and
what
what are the priorities in those
countries what
what is the immediate need for those
countries and that differs from country
to country right
um here in south africa the most
important thing right now
is ending the panemic and it's resuming
learning or if you go to another country
like
um rwanda uh protecting the planet is
very very important for
for rwanda if you go to nigeria
and education very very very important
pillars so
learning how to take our global
strategies and localize them for
each and every single corner of the
world in which we operated and we are
truly
global we in pan asia we in australia
we're in europe we
are in africa and and and in north and
south
um america because you know not
everything
is a one one size fits all we always
ensure that whatever we're doing
is driving that appropriate
measure and impact for that for that
specific region
but ultimately we then all come back
together
as a global organization to drive our
global mandate
which uh um is ending extreme poverty
and
in anything that is sort of um
impacting that mandate we then we then
um downstream it to localize it to
various
other pillar policy areas so so what is
actually
you know your role as senior manager of
global policy and government affairs
what does that
mean what does it mean government
affairs in the context of global citizen
right very good question um because it
really it truly does mean different
things for different organizations
for us my role really i sort of
drive the strategy around which
policy-focused areas we're going to be
advocating for
in the southern and east africa region
as well as west africa
and then the government affairs element
comes into play
where we then take those policy areas
and have to
drive the advocacy programs with
government to ensure that those policy
areas
are met that new commitments are made
by governments to address those policy
gaps
and and then also working with ngos
working with
um corporates because while as the
policies can be met and the gaps and the
policies can be addressed
the policies then have to be uh
implemented
government can only create an enabling
environment but ultimately it's
corporates its citizens
ngos civil society that actually have to
drive the implementation
of of of those policies so the second
part of it
of my role is really working with ngos
corporates
to create enabling environments for
those policies to thrive
so for instance on this bridging the
digital divide in education
we're currently working with the tech
sector the telcos
and various other corporates here in
south africa to make
financial and in-kind commitments
towards bridging the the digital divide
in in south africa an example just a
practical example of how that would look
like
is one of our partners is going to be
has um has committed over 2 million
rands
to drive fiber connectivity in remote
schools
so schools that were not previously
connected they will now be connecting
um those schools as part of their
commitment there's another
um telco that is going to be giving
bursary programs
for children from rural areas to study
animation and gaming so various
different types of
commitments by what we're calling a
telco coalition
calling and calling it a tech coalition
basically
of various south african companies
coming together to bridge the digital
divide in education
incredible now tell me a little bit more
about you know
your entrance into this world you know
you were
deep into technology as well you're
already you know working with incredible
companies
you could have chosen to go on on a
different path
a probably much more luxurious path why
why spend your time now in in global
citizen
you know beyond just the grand vision of
ending poverty
i don't know michael i i i think i think
we all get
born for a certain purpose for a certain
season
and for whatever reason and you'll often
find that
purpose in the work that you do um
and maybe yours through this podcast is
to tell stories and other people and to
you know
highlight what people are doing around
the world and that for you
is what you think you're here to serve
which is very very critical
telling stories is is a very very
important part of
of humanity creativity but also
um driving inspiration
around the world mine really is is
bridging the digital divide i i have
like i i have a sense and urge every day
to just wake up
and connect people and to
bridge inequality and to do whatever i
can in whatever roles that i've been
given and platforms
that i have been given to um bridging
equality or
any kind of business that i've ever been
involved in has always
seeked to do this um or seek to drive
development in some shape or form
um and this for me really it's the
reason i wake up at night
i wake up in the morning i it's the
reason why i breathe and live
amazing zombies this was so inspiring
thank you so much for coming and sharing
your story with me
and we're not done just yet i want to
spend the last couple of minutes going
back
and to talking about you and
take me back to your childhood what
really fascinated you
as a kid before you knew you know that
you're going to be doing all these
amazing things what really fascinated
you
it was books books fascinated me i think
books allowed me to dream and to go into
worlds that
drove my imagination and also to learn
so much about
other people's cultures other countries
what is happening in other worlds but
also to see myself
in in those stories it was very
difficult at the time when we were
growing up
um because it was applied to south
africa any sort of
consumption that we had from tv was not
something that we could identify with no
one looked like me
on tv and the world just seemed so far
off and so
i couldn't i couldn't um did not
resonate with me
and so books really helped me to to
dream to go
into um into worlds
far far far away and and and and even
inspire the career that i have today um
and i'll tell you why i mentioned the
the tv and the watching what you consume
and how that inspires dreams
in the u.s um the us has a lot of
female astronauts and that's because of
star wars
because in star wars there was that
amazing
amazing amazing female astronauts right
and a lot of them and so the u.s because
a lot of children grew up watching
star wars then they believed that they
could become
astronauts that as females they could
become astronauts
so what we consume what we watch the
content that we tell
which which is in line with what you do
is really really critical
and it's a very very important part of
driving equality in itself
and so i found that in in books
wow and where do you gain a source of
inspiration today
i think it's my mother she's
she's she is um she she's always
fighting for
for herself and i always tell her that
her fighting for herself allows me um to
fight for myself and fighting for
yourself basically is being a courageous
leader
it's being brave enough to get onto your
podcast
it's being brave enough to think that
you can change the world and work for
global citizen
and impact a million lives at a time you
know
that that that is so so so important for
me
um when she fights for herself it lets
me fight for myself
but also other people who i may not see
or know
that they watching my story and watching
my life it helps them
fight for themselves and believe that
truly they can be
and do whatever it is um they
they want to do and then also my kids
because they asked me the most absurd
questions like how my kids ask me crazy
crazy questions
and then it gets me thinking oh goodness
i actually need to read up about that
oh i need to do something about that or
i need to act on that and that really
stretches me
um as a person it really really does
stretch me because they get me thinking
in directions i never ever thought about
zombies so so cool and three words
that you would describe yourself uh i
would i would describe myself as a
go-getter
really progressive and uh connector
zomobiz thank you so so much i hope the
power comes back on
thank you for taking the time to share
your story with me
i i'm inspired by your journey your
mission your vision your execution
thank you for everything and stay safe
and stay healthy thank you
thank you michael you too stay safe